now his coaches but his players
teammates that was impressive
[Music]
like the way Bradley look out there
thank you fresh even though he missed
that last opportunities the package
[Applause]
he's fresh backdoor cut by Bradley bill
finishing right over bill fair look at
that this recognize it
backdoor six rebounds two assists
positional defense taken here by Detroit
but he got off the ground just enough to
throw it down 32 points per feel
Williams fake the pass comes up short
up ahead for peel peel punch it down
get TT the transition Brad the
exclamation point on that here's Neil
against born yet
Neil great hesitation
[Applause]
[Music]
super impressive to see how bill is
mixing it up he's passing it knocking
down shots on the perimeter now you come
out to the perimeter
linking the respect his drive taking
right to the basket nice
[Music]
is called
stop there by be
yes it was great pass to Bradley
villainy but better finish now his
coaches to his players teammates
was impressive rather kick didn't live
past from fog there look where he takes
off from let's so tries to find Elias
Ouma turns it over 300
it's feel
[Applause]
I think he's getting you sir this is
happening on a nightly basis
here's be trying to get to the
would search linzer's got 22 let's--oh
tries to jump into Brian gets back to
the steel
up ahead to feel feel jump over Lopez
and now a technical foul that's my
mindset Jay take it right to the bass
vaanga in the corner deal all the way
[Applause]
no it's not Sunday but let me check this
out breath
[Music]
Wow